wir zeigen euch heute wie fast food
ketten pommes herstellen da wird schon
bei den kartoffeln gespart und sebastian
lege erklärt euch den trick mit der
natronlauge so schild die industrie
[Musik]
sebastian nägel wird uns vorführen mit
welchen methoden man kartoffeln schnell
und effizient in pommes verwandelt haben
sie zu hause schon mal ihre kartoffeln
der waschmaschine geschält die industrie
macht fast genauso in die trommel hat
lege etwas sand papier geklebt das soll
die kartoffelschalen beim waschen
möglichst hauchdünn abschmierte auch in
der fabrik wird die schale nicht mit
messern entfernt sondern in rotierenden
trommeln weg geschrubbt nach dem
gleichen prinzip wie im sebastian lege
kartoffel waschmaschine
[Musik]
20 minuten und einen schnell waschgang
später zeigt sich der spielautomat marke
eigenbau hat funktioniert nur im detail
herrscht optimierungsbedarf ja immer
schon noch ein paar umdrehungen mehr
gebraucht aber da ist ja mal gar nichts
mehr dran
schnell und ohne teure handarbeit da
kann kein küchenmesser oder sparschäler
mithalten
um die schalen aber noch leichter und
garantiert vollständig abzubekommen
genügt ein kleiner griff in die
chemische trickkiste
die kartoffeln werden vor dem schälen
eingeweicht allerdings nicht im wasser
sondern in natronlauge
die kartoffel schale findet das
buchstäblich öffent nach einer stunde
ein weich zeit löst sie sich fast von
selbst
was der hand schon gut klappt ist für
shell maschine nun eine kleinigkeit bei
anderen produkten machen laugen und
säuren industrielles schälen überhaupt
erst möglich
mandarinen sind das paradebeispiel die
weißen schalen reste und zwischen
häuschen sind extrem schwer zu entfernen
müssen aber weg bevor es in die dose
geht
die lösung lautet salzsäure bei
mandarinen und pfirsichen wird sie
standardmäßig benutzt um die haut vom
fruchtkörper zu trennen
klingt unappetitlich ist bei
sachgerechter anwendung aber
gesundheitlich unbedenklich deklariert
werden müssen solche sehhilfen übrigens
nicht weil sie im fertigen produkt nicht
mehr enthalten sind
als verbraucher kann man also nicht
erkennen ob früchte oder gemüse chemisch
behandelt worden sind
höchstens am nach geschmack der
natronlauge im kartoffelpüree pulver
marken sieht das nicht aber wenn wenn
sie jetzt eine ganze kartoffeln essen
und da sagen schon einige grade
kartoffelkeller das schmeckt mir nicht
gut also ich möchte ihn übertragen wenn
mechanisch geschälte kartoffel lassen
übrigens wenn ihnen die kartoffeln in
kantine oder gaststätte ungewöhnlich
geld vorkommen ist das ein hinweis
darauf dass sie industriell geschält und
nach dem glauben bad nicht gründlich
genug gespült wurden
1 23 schale ist ab nur das sind noch
keine pommes das sind noch keine chips
wie schneidet die industrie so schnell
solche kartoffeln
da habe ich mir mal ganz spektakuläre so
ausgedacht
sebastian lege führt vor wie
pommeshersteller blitzschnell ganze
kartoffeln in viele kleine stäbchen
verwandeln können
herzlich willkommen in meiner kartoffel
schießbude gewinne gewinne gewinne
gewinne jeder dritte schuss gewinnt hier
die wasser getrunken nun gut das
katapult ist verbesserungsbedürftig
aber es geht auch mehr um das gitter
vorn am ende des trichters
trifft man das mit mindestens 80
stundenkilometer dann verwandelt sich
die kartoffel rupp in kleine stäbchen
[Gelächter]
schießen statt schneiden eine clevere
idee um kartoffeln in rekordzeit den
absolut gleichmäßige fritten zu
verwandeln
und auch für das problem der
zielgenauigkeit hat man in der industrie
eine einfache und effektive lösung
gefunden
wenn er pommes verbringen oft das
natürlich nicht mit dem katapult aber so
ähnlich
da wären die kartoffel mit einem
hochdruck durch eine hohe anlage
geschossen
dann gehen sie durch sieb und dann
kommen solche kleinen hübschen stifte
raus
fast die hälfte aller lebensmittel wird
heute von der industrie verarbeitet
schnell und effizient
es gehört eine menge ingenieurs kurz
dazu das können von köchen und
hausfrauen zu ersetzen
doch der aufwand lohnt sich für rund 12
cent pro kilo kaufen die hersteller zum
beispiel ihre kartoffeln und bieten die
pommes anschließend im discounter für
einen euro an
[Musik]
macht ihr eure pommes lieber selber oder
kräfte gerne zu den fertig geschnittenen
und wie die pommes bei den fastfood
ketten vom feld auf die hand kommen
zeigen wir euch jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mcdonald's und burger king bieten bei
ihren beliebtesten bürgern ein
ordentliches preis leistungsverhältnis
sparen sie dafür vielleicht bei dem
pommes
wie günstig die rohstoffe dafür sind
wollen wir bei einem der größten
produzenten für fastfood pommes
herausfinden an der holländischen grenze
in kevelaer
laut andreas triesen kartoffeln für
burger king an
aber hier wachsen keine normalen
speisekartoffeln das würden die böden
gar nicht hergeben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der verbraucher für speisekartoffeln
erwartet goldgelbe fälle kartoffel und
diese möglichkeit haben wir nicht bei
uns auf den böden auf den standort zu
produzieren und dann haben wir vor 20
jahren uns mehr der industriekartoffel
zugewandt denn bei der
industriekartoffel der sorte fontane
spielt der geschmack nur eine nebenrolle
hier kommt es vor allem auf eins an die
größe
[Musik]
eine dicke kartoffel gibt möglichst
viele lange stäbchen und das heißt für
die fabrik oder für die ache arbeiten
industrie eine hohe wertschöpfung heißt
bei so einer kartoffel muss man in der
pommes produktion wenig wegschmeißen das
bargeld
[Musik]
und das gleich doppelt wenn die
industriekartoffel ist wie billiger als
normale kartoffeln weil sie im
supermarkt kaum abnehmer finden würde
für 100 kilo bekommt baumriesen gerade
einmal zwischen neun und zwölf euro das
ist ein drittel weniger als für
speisekartoffeln
bauer dresens kartoffeln werden in
oberbergen in holland verarbeitet dort
produziert die firma lamb weston für
burger king mcdonalds und andere
anbieter
als erstes wird geprüft ob sich die
kartoffeln auch wirklich zur pommes
produktion eignen
die pommes sollten etwa 10 cm lang sein
entscheidend ist der stärkegehalt für
außen kross und innen vater pommes
gemessen per unterwasser gewicht war ein
unterwasser wert von 420 gramm
das ist gut für die pommes von burger
king die kartoffeln werden zunächst
gewaschen dann geschält
nicht etwa von hand sondern mit heißem
wasserdampf unter hochdruck
die produktion läuft vollautomatisch
obwohl hier täglich 300 tonnen
kartoffeln zu pommes verarbeitet werden
braucht die gigantische anlage kaum
mitarbeiter
auch das spart geld nachdem die panne
stent stifter geschnitten sind geht's ab
in die tiefkühlung
so kann genau nach bedarf produziert und
ausgeliefert werden
an einem tag verlassen hier fünf
millionen portionen koch industriell
hergestellte und dadurch unschlagbar
günstige pommes das werk
[Musik]
um es für mcdonald's und burger king ein
richtig gutes geschäft wo schmeckt es am
besten mcdonald's burger king oder ganz
woanders schreibt es uns in die
kommentare
und wo ist die besten lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt zeigen wir
euch auf unserem kanal zdf besser esser